[Audio Description not captioned]
[Music]
[Patricia Flatley Brennan, RN, PhD] NLM has
a 50-year history of conducting research
here on the NIH campus. We call this
our Intramural Research Program.
The research that we do uses mathematics and
computer science techniques to understand
truth and clinical experiences
by looking at large data sets.
[Valerie Florence, PhD] I believe that research
is the heart of the library and should be there.
and we are the world's
library and we have research.
It's important because it will advance the
approaches used in libraries all over the
world to manage and integrate and find
data so we can all get healthier faster.
[Sameer Antani, Phd] There's always more research
to be done. I think we are the cusp at the
beginning of trying to understand human bodies
and the information that is contained in it.
Each day, different parts of the NIH
are discovering new things. I think
that presents NLM with an opportunity to keep
toe-to-toe so that the two can work together.
[Brennan] Now, our Intramural Research
Program actually has two key components.
In our Computational Biology branch,
investigators use bioinformatics tools
to understand the structure and function
of genes and other kinds of protein data.
In our Computational Health Informatics
branch, our investigators are trying
to draw insights out of information
about the clinical process of patients
or the literature that describes clinical care.
What's exciting is that we've actually unified
these two programs under a single umbrella.
[Florence] A really special thing is training
and mentoring a next generation of scientists.
[Lauren Porter PhD] NLM has a really strong
track record in computation. There are a lot of
excellent scientists here and so I thought it
would be great to be able to work with them.
And I'm really happy to be here and
be able to like take chances that
I probably couldn't do in most other environments.
[Antani] We have an
opportunity before us where ...
all our findings, once translated, would
reduce the barriers to access to medicine,
improve treatability, improve early detection
which leads to better quality of life.
[Florence] Our whole goal is to
understand more about how living things
work in order to improve the health of humans.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]